alright let's figure out what the heck
happened last weekend news notes game
review Phil's is phil simms coming on I
haven't even talked to him yeah text him
hit him up okay now how are you guys I'm
good how are you uh just you know
looking at your jacket going now I've
only had a check it looks exactly I know
yeah left cracked like he like cornered
the market like he was the first person
ever to wear bomber jackets like he's
the only person that allowed I don't
know if he knew until woody told him
what a bomber jacket was in fact your
style pre Billy true or I got ok so high
style pre bleacher right was me text my
is Josh on a Tuesday you wear really
nice stuff we know you're on the podcast
when you're not it Sims his top button
thing yep without that window more style
is one of the most discussed topics in a
podcast comment section yeah
constantly well I think it's like for
people that don't know we've said woody
a long time woody is our makeup artist
and she also picks out clothes and stuff
for us new sweatshirt by the way yeah
looks a little camo can't see me I'm a
floating head but when I first got here
I was like a yellow polo blue docker
like a boat shoe I actually have a found
an unbelievable picture on my phone
today do you remember the yellow socks
you used to wear to the office so I have
a picture of you with by the way those
to everyone including my brother
everyone likes colorful socks yellow
ain't the one yeah everyone looks
ridiculous in yellow socks it's a note
for everyone out there it's you in a
wiper water down some jeans but you've
rolled up the Jean I was a style your
shins yeah and then you've got the
yellow but really what's happened is
I've gone to woody and gone
I am your I am your help me he is your
muse right it's not news it is no I am
your blank canvas it's a muse that's
what she is paid for by this why the st.
Laurent
oh my gosh what was I thinking that's a
Tuesday a bleacher report I'll put this
over to YouTube oh my gosh and I thought
I knew what I was
oh my gosh rocking the Red Solo Cup
probably two o'clock on a Wednesday
afternoon I've never worn color socks in
my life what color socks do you wear
black or white every day you don't have
a gray no why what do I need to employ
how many pairs of black socks do you Oh
probably 20 I feel like walking into his
house would be like a monochromatic
you'll be like one color everywhere I
have somebody my wife would like it
it's like organized by color oh yeah
yeah just well my wife would like
everything in the house to be white and
modern that's the way she always liked
my house yeah well if you want to see
what my socks are gonna look like in
person boy do we have a deal for you
Atlanta Atlanta Atlanta Atlanta email
Sims in love go at gmail.com as soon as
possible
Josh we were talking right before the
show we're getting to a point where
we're gonna be sold out we're getting to
a point where I'm being deemed by people
that work at places in the NFL going hey
I'm gonna be able to swing by and just
check out the show right and I go I
don't know yeah because you're gonna
have to email Fenric because there's
gonna be a list because capacity is a
thing so Tuesday yet what was it five
five Tuesday at five Wednesday at five
Thursday at 6:00 Friday at 4:30 email
Sims enough go at gmail.com give us your
name how many people if you want a
little brief description cuz apparently
a lot of people are telling Josh and we
have a lot of saints fans coming lot of
saints fans and a lot of survivor fans
coming it seems that I'm a bit of a draw
for this event people want to come and
talk about Survivor with me so maybe
that'll be the after show it'll just be
me up there doing a monologue about sir
what day do we do the show show Thursday
that's Thursday so why are we doing in
the Thursday cuz that's the big night of
Super Bowl week everyone's gonna be
there no one's you know wait for people
that have never been to Super Bowl I the
some stars will come in Tuesday but
that's usually where you're interviewing
a Herman Moore Orlando pace right
Wednesday that's when like ESPN and NFL
Network start broadcasting live from
there Thursday I've always felt is the
night day Thursday is when like
everyone's there and it's bumping and
that's when people are willing to make
predictions it just that's that's when
Super Bowl week I think really gets good
it's gonna do
day of Super Bowl week and Chris is
still gonna be asking me what day are we
doing the show I'll be like we did it
last night probably last night obviously
but I would tell people like Tuesday and
Wednesday are super fun because it's
gonna be a lot more relaxed and were
gonna have a lot more time to chill
afterwards yes rink that 19:42 go so
josh is gonna be sending an email next
week Pro Bowl week and bring the energy
we're gonna have some drink tickets the
cameras are gonna be on we're going to
cue a nays maybe bring some questions
hang out it'll be fun
and I'm hoping to really resonate with
the Falcons fans because the Falcons
Saints rivalry if the Saints get there
is becoming a thing why do the Falcons
fans actually like us the Atlanta may oh
yeah that's the funny thing right is
that no fan base really hated us for
longer than Atlanta and now I'm like
Atlanta fans I'm on your side
seriously Atlanta mayor Keisha bottoms
comes out and says I'm really rooting
for anybody other than the Saints and
then a New Orleans City Councilman Jay
Banks responded we're still coming and
it's not our fault that our team sucks
right
so we already got a little Atlanta in
New Orleans ravary it really is one of
the best sports rivalries where they
just come out each other's necks all the
time I feel like it went up another
level after Hurricane Katrina that's
when I way because the city's crossed
over and a lot of people for New Orleans
had to go to Italy exactly right and it
became like a lot of gang issues and
everything like that I feel like it
became way more personal from that point
I could be wrong but I also like I think
that it went up another notch when the
Falcons blew the 28 to 3 lead because no
fan base leaned into that harder than
the Saints I would say Saints fans
I see more fans that that have Florida
leaves and their handles that also say
by the way the Falcons blew a twenty
eight to three lead in Patriots fans
right like they really enjoyed that so
it's a it's a I'm cool I'm happy to be
in the middle so do we have same fans
that already bought the tickets yes
we're not buying any ticking or emailing
me and they're saying I'm a Saints fan I
can't wait to see left right it's just
their jinxing their team a little I
honestly oh that's the other thing that
I'm loving the guy coming out and saying
we're gonna go to Atlanta whoever comes
out earlier in the week with the
confidence who said that the City
Commission the City Council yet
yeah but we might have to do with like a
roast where we let some of the Saints
fans on stage make you get 20 seconds
say whatever you want to laugh down if
the Saints are in the Super Bowl were
probably not gonna have a choice
oh yeah I think we have to do that
speaking of the Super Bowl the
officiating crew came out referee is
gonna be John Perry by the way I went
back and looked he did do a Patriots
Super Bowl and it was the 2011 Patriots
giant Super Bowl so I'm sure if the
Patriots get there they'll hear big fan
of John one of my favorite rests seems
like a good guy his field judge for the
game yeah yeah boy yeah yeah Yves Zimmer
hey you got pushed by a Superbowl rep
yes I did how lucky I am
he probably earned his way with that
last check mark right there that you're
you're good enough to handle the Super
Bowl sidelines I implore you
if you haven't seen it yet go on YouTube
watch Sims and left go the show they
slowmode it and they zoomed in on it and
to watch him do the full hit and then
also like you see him really push you
the Zapruder film of it makes it that
much better
right there was nobody on the grassy
knoll huh - look - look to your left
till you look to your left and I realize
that it was all mud right and if you
would have face-planted you would have
come up in all mud right it what's his
name Steve Zimmer yeah he's just lucky
he did that on a football field cuz if
he did that outside of Arrowhead Stadium
deep [ __ ] if you would have bumped to
you I would've gave me I would have gave
him the Pedro Martinez Don Zimmer
treatment okay I had to grab his head
right on the ground that was still the
best moment that was pretty good the
best part is if you look at Pedro
Martinez's fingers they're indenting it
in his head yeah and it is so fat he was
such a cool dude Zimmer - he used to
come to our practices and tan out yeah
it's yeah he's dead now Zimmer what was
his name that we just said it it wasn't
that it wasn't Don Zimmer
was it I don't think it was I think you
might be right yeah bench coach for the
job
I just I was like what are the odds that
Don Zimmer's emergency yes right there
was a little history made for your
Collegiate Conference the big 12 hmm and
a question made its way was this on
reddit Josh I think I just saw it I just
saw an article on Twitter man okay news
okay calm for big 12 quarterbacks and at
home you answer this question - so Sims
pause yeah there are four big 12
quarterbacks to start an NFL playoff
game in history only one has won a
playoff game
who are the four and who's the winner
give yourself a second to think all the
fans at home think four big 12
quarterbacks to start a playoff game
only one won the playoff game you can
pause your podcast now if you want to
come up with are you ready yeah go ahead
okay so I'm one so by the way when Josh
asked me this right off the top my head
I got three of the four and I would have
gotten four but I went a different way
so mahomes has to be yep he's the one
the one yeah okay but a couple of homies
who the hell am I missing here I know
I'm gonna miss some obvious ones big 12
quarterbacks damn Seneca didn't start
any games they're damn Sam Bradford
didn't make any payoff games holy crap
give you hints if you're stumped but
yeah give me a give me a school all
right well well no it's gonna give it
away
yeah all right hold on I'm missing
somebody obvious oh no I was gonna say
in the morning them accounts went to A&M
the oldest yeah hold on hold on I gotta
start going through the schools here
Colorado didn't have anybody that would
have done that
Baylor Oh rg3 bang every gallery ok so I
got those three too and I guessed on the
last one Brandon Weeden okay because he
play I thought he played in that Texans
playoff right but I don't think he
started well this next one is in Chaplin
I should get it is the easiest one it's
the easiest one easiest one boy yeah you
but hold on Vince didn't play a playoff
game and that's what I thought but it's
the fourth one he started one for the
Titans did he really
in oh seven oh seven I do
don't remember them hi hi I didn't think
that Vince Young played in the playoff
game in the game that is so funny that's
that was my issue Yeah right so oh seven
I'm trying to think man those titan
teams are good but i can't we were on
that team at what year oh wait oh wait
yeah eight and ten they lost to the
Chargers in the playoffs Oh out in
lausanne Diego correct I do remember it
now 17 to 6 yeah that's right yeah ok
all right so you're on a list it's it's
listen this list yeah Patrick Mahone
Vince Young rg3 Chris Sims arguably the
best of them all athleticism you run
another list this week too there was a
graphic going around Instagram Broncos
starting quarterback since John Elway
retire oh that's comedy were there ooh
let's see plumber plumber Cutler Sims
Orton I could read him King reisi Paxton
greasy Cutler Chris Miller Brock
Osweiler Tebow Orton Berman Peyton
Manning Trevor Simeon Danny canal Darius
Jackson and Chris Sims man Darius
Jackson to Dan he started a game holy
cow
over Darius Jackson the Notre Dame
quarterback yeah it's funny I look at
two franchises Broncos and dolphins
right and they're still obsessed with
their 80s quarterback yeah they are I
mean those two were it's who's gonna
fill in the shadow of John Elway and Dan
Marino the city was literally formed
around the fabric of fabric of them
though like that's where it's we're
gonna denver Elway car dealerships and
all that start at his face and name was
everywhere and Marino was kind of the
same way because wayne Huizenga got him
involved in a lot of the gated
communities and all that stuff in South
Florida where he got ball golf courses
and all those things right all right
let's get to the news there's a lot to
get to we're gonna start off first with
one of the best uses of left go PR by a
player I've seen all right Antonio Brown
apparently reached out to Jerry Rice and
said this is what Jerry Rice said he's
talking about running the hill with me
doing all that and just working out and
just picking my brain I don't know if
it's gonna happen because it's up to
Shanahan and Lynch but I'm all for it if
he wants to come on board he
wants to come here bad right this is an
amazing move by Antonio Brown you reach
out to a legend in a city and what a
legends want more than anything they
want to share their experience with
younger people right everyone thinks
that they have the keys and the key is
just bust your ass and work hard but
anyway yeah now San Francisco Niners
fans the Niners are the favorite to land
Antonio Brown in Vegas they're going
Jerry is gonna mentor Antonio Brown and
then Antonio Brown with Jorge fenokee
let me up
yeah Jorge Kittel Antonio Brown Jerick
McKinnon Jimmy Garoppolo this is a great
team yes and it could be yes but it's a
great left go PR right it's great move
by him but you don't want to Antonio
Brown the Niners I mean I just you know
I'm again I haven't talked to my buddy
in a while we've texted a few times but
all together like I just would say buyer
beware
I mean buyer beware I mean we know
enough stories that Antonio Brown has
been part of dysfunction in Pittsburgh
for the last seven years I mean a number
of issues and I mean any head coach
should be scared of Antonio Brown
because when you get Antonio Brown and
he starts to go off the handle you get
accused of lack of institutional control
and that's all we talk about with my
tamo now because of one guy one guy has
made us all think Mike Tomlin lost
control of the team that and because
Le'Veon Bell made a business decision
not to play at martavis Bryant right I
think in trouble yeah right which again
he didn't draft martavis Bryant and he
can't go home with them and go like no
put the weed down man or yeah don't do
that so like that's where a head coach
may be where they're well on the field
and got in a fight with a player yes
okay that'll give your right that's
something that's certainly Mike Tomlin
should watch out Joey Porter's been
doing that his whole life I mean his
dogs have eaten like three neighbor's
dogs too so timeout that's a story
that's the story he's had his dog his
dogs have attacked neighbor a neighbor's
dog I think on two separate occasions
you can look that up to verify so we
don't get that they've like killed the
neighbor's dogs how's a guy who's an
animal person I mean ridiculous okay so
I just googled Joey Porter dog right
first headline that comes up Joey
Porter's dog gets loose kills miniature
horse miniature horse that was the point
right there's another incident where a
dog right Joey Porter's dogs kill again
yes
and then third headline Joey Porter's
dog kills a horse so yeah seems like
this is so here's the thing if something
went onto their yard if dogs can kill
dog can't get loose and kill a horse in
someone else's yard Wow see I'm gonna
bring in nuance to the show giving some
intricate details that you weren't
expecting this Bruce Arians came out
pulled out Antonio Brown I heard pretty
much saying called him a diva
he was really good as rookie year but it
eventually became a diva and tanio Brown
just responded on Twitter right here's
what he tweeted yeah he didn't draft me
he drafted a manual sander same guy who
missed rehab to go on networks to talk
about me on situation he has zero clue
Arians now whereas a Kangol hat and
glasses but I'm a diva I done seen it
all then they say we friends dot lyin he
spelled Lian Li en mu which is lean lean
lean oh my god and then a beautiful left
go PR just came on my phone but three
hundred and twenty pound defensive
tackle can do backflips to all the
college athletes out there I'd like to
remind you about Jason pierre-paul if
you are a large man and you can do a
backflip or dunk a basketball do it now
and post it on social media
Owen because it's gonna improve improve
your draft stock by a rounder so is that
who is it did it say the name or the
school or the guy former Western
Illinois defensive tackle Kaylin
Saunders hunt 320 here's what they wrote
stock in the NFL draft might go up half
of this things like this that get in
people's head and they go what we know
is athleticism do you see that one
backflip II do know because the time of
defensive tackle does a backflip and
then sacks Tom Brady will be the first
Nathaniel amazing though
Nathaniel Hackett yeah going to Green
Bay a lot of people hit us on Monday
night and said they were excited to
watch years in love go combination great
great and it great higher by Matt
Lafleur to who's somebody who's you know
hopefully realizes like hey it'd be good
for me to have somebody in the building
with me that's you know kind of a tried
and trusted offensive coordinator to
help me
along the way and we can be a tandem and
work together like and I talked about
this a lot this weekend even with like I
was in the car with Dungey at one point
in the game and I was like I don't get
why Nate Hackett hasn't like been
involved in like more conversations for
offensive coordinators talks I mean the
guy invented an offense like we said for
a year where he made 90 million
different ways to throw the three throws
that Blake bortles can throw and there
to me that is genius and it's up he was
the number six offense and football last
year would Blake bortles so yes I think
that him and LeFleur domination look at
their offense this year when he went
down look right Leflore was watching a
lot of film of the Jaguars Titans sure
and I'm sure he flipped it over and went
man how are they moving the ball with
Blake bortles
the quarter was a valid point right I
just love though that now we've got two
good minds in there with Aaron mhmmm
that are not running the same system
that are not running the same styles I
saw an interview with Matt Lafleur where
he came out and said everything is about
distraction in disguise yeah we want to
be repetitive in our play calling
but dial it up so that you don't know
we're gonna get to your Rams film later
but that's the reason people are hiring
these Sean McVeigh guys sure because if
you from your notes and the Rams name it
was the same things over and over again
they all look the same but they're all
different yes and if they can do that
with Rodgers who can throw it better
than anybody right here we go no doubt
about it
Nathaniel is amazing with play-action
and boo legs and stuff like that that'll
be of course right in the wheelhouse of
what Rodgers does and it's a similar
it's still the West Coast offense so the
learning curve for Rodgers gonna be
nothing right it's really he's gonna
have some of this like you know slant
flat might have been lying in one
offense and now he's gonna and now it's
gonna be bangle I mean it's gonna be
like something very similar either way
there is a internet meme challenge right
now it's called the anterior tribe so
you've heard it I have yes my wife is
told me about it because there's nothing
they like doing more than going back in
their phone and looking at old pictures
right feelingly yeah my wife was hot ten
years ago man I looked really good
well is there and what you're doing is
you're showing what you look like and
then
people want to show their glow up right
you know how they've changed Aaron
Nathaniel Hackett going from Blake
bortles to Aaron Rodgers is the greatest
blow-up of all time
yeah if this was a ten year challenge
its undefeated
yeah he I don't even think he's gonna
understand what he can do now no I know
I'm running for Detroit and Green Bay
which he must have been like mad 2/4
racks I could just throw it anywhere on
the field but yes this is gonna be like
you know kid in a candy store I'm just
worried that he's gonna go to Rogers and
go do you feel comfortable throwing and
out and Rogers gonna go yes I'm
comfortable so he leaves Jacksonville
yeah which means Jacksonville needs an
OC and they hire John Dee Filippo which
sets up dad Nick we have breaking news
the Philadelphia Eagles have traded Nick
Foles for seven first-round picks to
play with John D Filippo in Jacksonville
is that what you thought the first time
yes that's setting up for that it's
certainly I mean there's there's not
only that with the fact that falls will
no D Philippa's offense and be able to
transition transition nicely but I also
think of guys like Marone and Tom
Coughlin and at the end of the day they
come from the Parcells school of
coaching which is like Belichick of
course and they believe in big pocket
quarterbacks they they really do their
their thing is no I want a quarterback
that can stand in the pocket and that
makes words like was he is bikes a big
dude he didn't want that somebody with
big hands that's gonna be able to throw
the ball in the elements when it comes
playoff time December January or
anything like that and I think that
they're getting defillippo after a
humbling moment yep where hopefully it's
not just two receiver routes with max
protect and Marrone is gonna make him
run that's the big thing that's that's
what I thought was so fun is to go from
Zimmer tomorrow right if you didn't
learn you're gonna learn again yeah
exactly right morones not gonna I mean
morones an EXO line coach he's gonna
make you run so he's not gonna have a
choice and a lot of these and these
football games so the Eagles have
announced they're moving forward with
Carson Wentz as their quarterback it's
the number one question that everyone
asks me all the time what should they do
what should they do before I go do you
have any insight information on what's
going on I don't have any insight in
firm
right now talking about on Monday while
we were taping that or Tuesday while we
were taping the show maybe you were just
speculating about franchise tagging for
you certainly that would be on the table
the franchise tag him and then hold him
hostage and then try to trade him and
then let him renegotiate a contract with
whatever team that wants to trade right
but he could also be a jerk that way and
say well I'm not signing the franchise
and then he's kind of got the power as
well he also hasn't so there's a mutual
option
yeah it's 25 million dollar 120 million
20 million when he can buy out for two
million if he pays the team out pays the
team two million dollars so he'd be
giving back the bonus he got did he get
a million dollar bonus after week 17
yeah something like that they gave it to
him even though we didn't even though we
didn't get it right it's the right
decision Carson Wentz is still better
than Nick Foles I don't care what
anybody says we've seen one season of
Nick Foles be successful in his career
in the NFL and just think seven and two
right and I'm just going to recognize
once again remind everybody that the
best Eagles team I ever saw was the one
when Carson Wentz was the quarterback
the year he should have been the MVP
last year even though he just missed the
last two games with the Frank Reich out
that was the best team I ever saw Billy
was unstoppable at that point and he was
the MVP in football and we saw again
this year now yes Nick Foles got the
benefit of the doubt of taking over the
reins when kind of the team got healthy
and got things straight and started to
get back to really what made them
successful a little bit more last year -
but like did everybody forget the start
of the season - everybody forget in 1944
for 117 yards and two interception or
one interception against Atlanta whoa
holy cow did everyone forget wak'd week
- when yeah he threw for 300 yards but
all of it was bull crap yardage at the
end of the game no my issue is not about
remembering foals as faults right
because I think that he is a good
quarterback in his league yes I think
that they're forgetting Wednesday's
capability I think that's a two year and
I I think I watched the Saints game and
there was multiple times the second half
or I said this is a Carson Wentz game
not a foals game because Lattimore is
back and the 50/50 balls were not there
and the wide receivers for the Eagles
weren't able to get it they needed some
that was a running threat and if where
was time to run for sure when where
there were times where I just said
whence needs to truck somebody and go
for six yeah you mean poles no no I'm
saying went like they need whens to be
all we got you they don't have them
right and and that's an aspect that
foals doesn't have yeah foals has better
touch than whens definitely like he can
drop it in there Ecklie also he's just
got a better rapport with some of the
receivers like he has a better rapport
with Al Shean and that's the fact sure
and Carson I think has a better rapport
with Earth's yeah and full I mean if
Collinsworth talked one more time about
how he played basketball and he knows
how to enter in the post I get it yeah
but no when says the guy but I thought
foals had a quote that went exactly to
what we've always said yeah we said last
year with the four teams that were in
the championship games with Keenum
bortles and foals it's not all about the
quarterback and Folles said that - he
said teams are gonna build around the
quarterback but as a QB you got to know
you're off and she got to know special
teams you got to talk to guys during the
game it's not all about you that's
something that's so important it's
something that resonates that's
something that when we're down the
defense always knows we're gonna get the
ball back he later said the quarterback
is a piece of the puzzle and you create
that confidence in the locker room and
you let guys know who you are it's just
it was all set we're just the whole
thing there's more - yeah but it's not
all about the quarter but no I mean yeah
you know Nick Foles heaven he was crap
with the Rams that year right so would
every other quarterback been crap that
year if they put Tom Brady on that same
Rams team
it would have been crap I mean there's
no other way to say it so not my home no
well I mean no but that's like that's a
different guy I mean that's that's why
we're all fawning over him because he
can run up between the guard in the
center gap and throw the ball through
the tackle and tight end gap for a
20-yard gain like he did the other night
I mean nobody in football can do that
not even number 12 I don't think so
yeah I mean that's that's different you
know but yes everybody needs support and
it's just it's a team game again look at
that look at New England this week I
mean we talked about it a number of
times Brady didn't throw a ball over
five yards until like the end of the
first quarter but yet he was probably
like ten for ten and marching down the
field but because he had support and a
good plan and everything worked around
I want to give a shout out to Kevin
Clark of the ringer who had a really
good article that the Patriots teach us
what the NFL is all about yes and one of
his lines was you're gonna hear a lot
about this in the next two weeks the top
four offenses are in the NFL playoffs
yeah and everyone's gonna say that's the
modern-day NFL yeah well last year's
final four was the top four defenses all
right there he goes Vikings bag Wars
Patriots so this isn't a trend
the only trend is the Patriots were in
both and I thought it was a great point
by him right because they can adapt
right and it's about changing and I
think that that I'm so excited to break
this down tomorrow and go what is
Belichick going to do to mahomes that
the rest of the NFL is gonna steal for
the next five years yes I hear you and
hear to that point too with what you're
saying about the offense is - I think
that even further that along because
everybody thinks offense is now is it's
the it's the spread College is taken
over let me just remind everybody third
best team running the football in the
NFL Los Angeles Rams
fifth best team at running the football
in the NFL New England Patriots sixth
best team in the NFL running the
football New Orleans Saints
so again New England and these good
teams are showing us two that you know
they've evolved past this like Oh spread
blah blah blah they've started a new age
where like I think some teams are still
like trying to catch up into the spread
crap and they're gonna I was a new way
to play I don't even know what my point
was but I just thought that was
interesting off of your time just saying
it's not always about throwing it fits
it was right exactly right that's what
I'm trying to say uh and then I love
that how heroes me came out and said
look we're gonna do what helps our
football team right cuz I love Nick
Foles yeah I do too I don't need him to
walk away wherever he wants because if
he ends up in New York yeah I got a
problem right like I don't want to see
Nick Foles on the Giants twice a year
yeah I hear you hey they got to do
what's best for the Philadelphia Eagles
it's a business Nick Foles understands
that I you know between Howie Roseman
Doug Peterson and Nick Foles like I
think they're very mature logical
respectable human beings that will
figure out a way to make this work for
everybody they
been up front with foals from the
beginning yes they've been honest with
him and the other thing I love some GM's
in this league don't trade a lot how he
has treated a ton right so I'm not
worried that he's gonna find a suitor
because how he is really good at calling
around yeah the problem right now I was
talking about this in the kitchen we've
had 11 new quarterbacks enter the league
in the last three years and they filled
all the holes five quarterbacks this
year the year before mahomes Watson try
Biscay the year before that with the
year before that Goff went DAC like like
and they've all hit yeah so sometimes
you get the misses and then oh we still
have an issue there really it's Giants
Jaguars Washington and who else as far
as just needing eating a quarterback
yeah you're right it's not as many teams
as everybody thinks you're right no when
I look at the NFL I go well it's not
going to Giants in Washington you're not
trading him in the division right
because they traded Donovan in the
Cincinnati can maybe make a case or you
can make a case right and Zach Taylor
right I mean yes but but they traded
Donovan to Washington because what
Donovan was done and Washington thought
they could get more out of right you
know more about that but it's
Jacksonville yes
Miami's in that combo to Oakland no
they're gonna stay with Derek Carr I
mean I think that there would be
pitchforks and flames in the street if
they decide to get rid of him - yeah I
think grows all the guys I think Gruden
realizes that but no I'm hoping they get
something for them whether it's a
sign-and-trade or a franchise tag in
trade or an option in and trade Miami
would make a lot of sense
Brian Flores going down there he's for
me who does he bring in this is oh city
well I know it's only depend but I know
still institutional wise he's gonna have
the New England thought of I need a guy
that can go up to New England in
December or the Jets in December or
Buffalo in November and be able to throw
in those elements and that's what foals
can do there's nothing I enjoy more
right than trading with the Miami
Dolphins because when we got a second
round pick for AJ Feeley right it was
one of the best trades of all time we
were ready to offer Carson Wentz for
Laremy Tunsil and two first rounders on
Sunday I think Laremy Tunsil two first
rounders would be a beautiful fall right
tonsils good tonsils really good and
then I don't know what's going on with
Jason Peters so it fills
I don't
I'll be asked yeah it would be awesome I
just don't think you're trading for a
quarterback and then giving away his
blindside protection right the only
other thing there's a few more news and
notes one you got really upset about
Matt Negi
and talking about parkies appearance so
apparently Cody parky met with Matt Nagy
wrapped up the season Cody parky didn't
say hey in a few days I'm gonna go on
national television and talk about what
it's like to fail and then Nagy
subsequently went into a press
conference and said it's all about we
it's not about me we always talk as a
team we went as a team that felt more
like a me thing yeah then a we thing
right and that pissed you off well it
pisses me off because I don't feel like
he necessarily has lived by that credo
since he has taken over you know in the
NFL and I'm gonna find something real
quick so just bear with me because I
have a picture in my phone and I want to
bring it up of the graphic exactly this
will always bother me if anybody's on
the square what screen connects it to me
I'll put it on the YouTube okay but
let's read it for people so this is
Mitchell true Biscay second game of the
year going out on the field against
Seattle right in the Monday Night
Football game and he had just had a bad
second half against Green bad second
half or he gave him a 22 3 lead and they
blew it but they're gonna blame it's a
true Biscay added of the fact that I
know Nagy is was telling people behind
the scenes at that time too that you
know his full scope of the offense
wasn't in and that they tried to like
really show off chase Daniels and
preseason game number four against a
bunch of guys that aren't gonna be in
the NFL and they play one coverage that
game the whole game and this was back
when booger on the broadcast was just
restating whatever somebody would tell
him in pre-production no doubt about it
so yes that bothered me because when I
was head coach noting that his quote
card is I have to pull back what I am as
a play caller wow that is a great
endorsement for your starting
quarterback and then on his place sheet
it says be bu yeah so that bothers me
and I just give free pass on that I'm
not giving her a free pass on that that
was some bull crap coach speak where
yeah I'm all about the team until we
talk about me and then it than it is me
and if they mess up it's them because
there's not me I mean that's that's
basically what that came down to and yes
I'm
still my ass is still read about that
Who am I left carpi opre
yeah have you ever really wanted to like
end something with someone but you
didn't want to be that one to end it so
you waited until they made a mistake and
then blamed it all on that right I guess
I'm talking more relationships than
anything yeah but it sounds like Matt
and Aggies going I really didn't like
that Cody parky thing and I'm gonna use
that as part of the reason to follow up
the doinking with that that's
unacceptable I didn't just get rid of
him cuz the Dinks right but to follow it
with that that's a good thought as well
right now yes I know and you know again
I'll challenge anything to with it so
was Matt nagi's full scope of his
offense as a play caller was that it
well we saw in Detroit and the loss to
the New York Giants with chase Daniel
cuz if that was it
then damn it just ain't that good I
don't know what else to say and yes that
will bother me until he can you know
make me feel better over time
- offensive line stuff really quick I
think the early winners of the offseason
are the Denver Broncos I didn't see this
until today it was down for their head
coaching race between Mike Munchak
offensive line coach of the Pittsburgh
Steelers and Vic Fangio defensive
coordinator of the Bears they hire
Fangio they just got Mike Munchak as
their offensive line coach they got both
now and the main reason is Munchak
wanted to be near his family in Denver
that's phenomenal we talked about
getting teams that have a lot of head
coaches on staff it just provides
leadership all over the place but Mike
Munchak is arguably the number one
offensive line coach teacher in the
league up there was scar nekke and those
guys and you get him in Denver who has
had offensive line issues for the better
part of the last five years right what a
steal what a steal I mean really one of
the best coaches in football in general
I don't even care offensive line
whatever it may be he's he understands
the game in his totality and yeah for a
guy like Vic Fangio he's gonna play
wants to play defensive style a football
I'm sure control the line of scrimmage a
little bit play-action passes who they
named it Oh see there yeah i blanking
okay so one guy from the Niners oh the
QB coach from Kyle I know I'm blanking
on his damn name right looks like Nick
Mullens right he does a little bit you
rocky oh yeah damn I can't the
his damn name but either way okay that
would fit well because Munchak the way
he wants to run the ball is very similar
to the way Kyle would run the ball as
well sure Ella
skander Ella right so that is like what
you said left go they knocked it out of
the park with two top-notch coaches and
Fangio and Munchak it's mine checks
amazing but I got through Munchak when I
was in Tennessee
I mean CJ 2k and they're running the
football his eye for talent and some of
the guys we drafted it was off the
charts
Mike Colombo just or mark Colombo just
got a three-year extension for the
cowboy who in offensive line coach
you've talked about reading defenses and
all that stuff yeah I always thought it
was offensive line coach kind of like a
rah-rah
let's kill them kind of guy right but of
my brains there yeah really it's really
there their trench evaluators yes
exactly right and they understand
through a lot of the times like a Mike
Munchak he understands what really works
and doesn't work the whole family
because he played exactly right and he
just goes well that's not realistic to
ask in the left guard or damn I remember
when we had a play a defense and that's
as disruptive is this and we did this so
they can draw from their experiences let
alone teach great technique and then
also get in the ear of the offensive
coordinator and go you know run the
inside zone here Oh
let's run 96 power King here yes right
and do whatever it is so that's what's
the greatness about Munchak now the
surprising move to wrap up the notes is
that the Colts fired their offensive
line coach Dave do Guglielmo yes good
Jer
you you've been pumping this guy up for
a while right there's been no unit that
I think got more praise the end of the
season and the Colts offensive line
right and it was shocking to a lot of
people yes one of the stories it's come
out that I'm gonna kind of share with
you guys makes a little bit of a sense
Reich coach Frank Reich described googs
awhile as blunt and direct and more of a
throwback coach yes when you combine
this with this story of Denzel good so
Denzel good was an offensive lineman for
the Colts that got waived midway through
the season asked for his release and the
reason now to the athletic is might
explain him Denzel Goods brother was
fatally shot after the Houston game in
like week four and good
that offensive line coach Guglielmo was
upset that he had left the team and in a
meeting in his office a month later told
good that he was a failure because he
wanted the offensive lineman to play
through everything good said quote I
came back after my brother was murdered
and I was doing a lot of personal issues
that didn't sit well with Dave he wanted
players that would fight through he told
me that as long as I was there I would
never play for him again he then went to
Chris Ballard and asked for his release
and then he got it yeah
so that makes a lot of sense yes it does
but then our guy quit Nelson came out
right and he put a whole thing on
Twitter oh and he wrote
let me see if I can find it not
everybody's old school I'll just talk
why you you find it but not everybody's
old school hey I am the type of guy that
like if my dad died during the week I'd
be playing on Sunday and we could talk
to my dad about that it's just it's what
I would do I think he would want me to
do that but not everybody lives it that
way I mean not everyone hat is expected
to do exactly right not everybody is
expected to live that but there is
certainly an old-school fad like we saw
Brett Favre do it and those kind of guys
yeah people from Belichick and all of
them yes that's the way they operate but
there are people who operate in a
different way and don't look as football
as life it's their job they like to play
it but there's bigger things and that's
where it kind of can differentiate its
debate as old as time yeah you have a
baby that day are you gonna play the
game no I miss the birth you know that
all the time I almost didn't miss OTAs
when my little girl I was gonna miss my
OTA when my little girl was born I was
like whatever they don't need me there
listen to me that sounds crazy yeah I
know I know but I wasn't gonna miss it
on your deathbed you're never gonna look
back you know damn I wish I took those
extra snaps under John Wayne's stand but
I might go damn what I worth of my joy I
saw it scarred me forever
[Laughter]
I don't know why that that was perfectly
fine it's my wife I don't want to think
about your wife's birthing man it's
crazy when you see that I don't know the
prime to stay above date all I did I
stayed above they told me they were like
do you want to come down here and I was
like nope I'm good over here if I was
the doctor Otis said get under center
put my hands there and make sure you get
agent I didn't even cut the cord on
either one of my kids that's like no doc
you got it you're an expert I'm a
quarterback
how'd it go hey you're not cutting that
out Josh here's what Quinton Nelson
tweeted out I'm seeing a lot of
speculation talk from outsiders talking
bad about coach googs I just want to
address it he has a great fundamental
coach and a great person he unified us
as an offensive line and pushed us to be
the best anything else said about him is
false but of all the guys in the NFL if
I gotta go to the alley right now quit
Nelson might be my god oh because I
think he'd go I'm here for you at him
like him not wearing sleeves I did I
told you let me talk about that on
Monday I know like I was so I'm getting
ready to do my hit right how loud the
stadium is to start the game and like
literally and they're like okay it's
gonna be coming to you in like 30
seconds and all of a sudden out of the
Colts locker room cuz I'm right outside
the Colts locker room is here comes
Quinton I mean he's such even for the
NFL he is such a huge human cuz he's
truly like a cinderblock with a head and
arms that's what he is built like and he
comes out with this tank top and I mean
just unfazed and as he's walking down
the hallway there's people who are
working on the field and trying to clear
snow and he's the type of guy where they
all stop in their tracks and they go
look at that [ __ ] guy right there I
don't know I don't think they knew who
he was but they're just like look at
that [ __ ] guy holy cow
because his shoulders in his arm he's
got no neck and a big block looks like
with his shirt off like he's still
wearing pads yes he does exactly right
exactly you're not cutting that out wait
so what happened so he walked on the
field and did it mess you up for your
hip no it did not but I just I was
sitting there in awe too like gosh I
mean I saw him every week at Notre Dame
last year and I still when I see him I
go whoo
he is one big mf'er he were it's it's we
got to call Phil when he's ready we said
I told him 4:20 do you not want to do it
damn no can we do can we do 5:10 5:15
Wow there's no way no all right then
let's do Phil now I'm sorry yeah hey
look you're booking your Booker let's
get him on the phone Nicky G yeah all
right all right I totally forgot to
remind him earlier today some booking
producer you are
I just can't but I've started talking
about birth I just couldn't I looked at
Josh the whole time and says yeah have
you talked to him at all this week
my dad missed my birth for practice of
starting right there yeah he should
answer here in a second hello hello
hello Phillip these two guys doing today
we're talking about NFL players missing
the birth of their child for practice
and we hear you fit into that category
you know it's all right dad I would have
done the same
no Kris says he would do the same thing
too hey that's right
my wife but I said yet don't even dare
miss practice stay there really good
other guy get any reps take them all to
heck with them and I'm not kidding
that's exactly what she would say you
better suck it up Phil yeah she also
told my dad when he woke up with the
inner ear infection in 1993 she really
didn't say suck it up at first he says
bull whatever you're gonna go play
awesome god okay uh plus he's gonna have
a little sympathy for me but that's the
way it goes but you know hey Adam can I
talk to you for a second I would love it
what would you think if you had a son
and you know he had this good thought
and it was really good and and I'm you
know the father's always given the son
all kinds of things about the games and
stuff and so that's good not turn him on
TV and watch him on radio and he's
repeating some things that we talked
about so good I contributed a little bit
to his life and he you know and then I
you know listened to him yes was it
yesterday or Monday I don't know when oh
well you know New England's playing the
Chargers and you get Bill Belichick two
weeks and he did it did this defense
against Seattle look what he did look
what he did against Atlanta there ah
yeah and then he does it against the
charges you run the same defense what
did you expect in two weeks and I
thought why the hell didn't you tell me
that last week we talked about this game
like
and he goes well I set it during the
week didn't you hear me oh well I'm
sorry son I work too I didn't get to
hear every word you said during the week
he called me on Sunday after the game
and I went on that spiel with him after
New England charges and he goes well
damn why did you say that to me earlier
in the week that's a great point but we
do have that type of relationship where
yes I should have probably gave you that
but we talked football I and yes we
certainly do you z1 ain't come on listen
that's like you know it's like the sore
thumb I mean that's the first one to
come out of your mouth tell me about all
these other things oh you know oh yeah
okay but tell me something good it's
really upsetting but one what it's so
simple I can't believe I didn't think of
it
Chargers Phil I talked to them they go
man yeah that's right I didn't think of
that either I'm my god okay so you know
oh well so you know like I got some
really good stuff for the games this
weekend you know to me just to me when
you turn on Sunday the first time you're
going to hear some stuff and it's going
to be different promise you yeah it's
cut you'll hear it from me nice so what
about that they went every game and
that's it and then you know mahomes I've
never seen anything like it so it's a
really cutting edge stuff don't you
think yeah Phil did you see your son
getting hit by the referee on Sunday
well Adam of course I did and I think I
saw it first from you
nice what was you what were you thinking
what what I think I well first I just
went damn you know why you so close to
the field and the actions coming your
way but I was just glad he didn't fall
down right and I'm glad he didn't get
hurt and all that stuff but Peter fell
down and like hitting the mud and just
said then it would've really been on
every TV show yes but since he someone
has somewhat athletic ability on him and
of course he
puts all the faith in his Lebron Shoes
kept him up oh my god
you know tennis shoes in the mud when I
think about going out in the mud not
losing tracks like a world my tennis
shoes yeah that's what I think of so
yeah that's a good what are you trying
to give LeBron more money hey no you're
right he's good in that department yeah
yeah okay let's sell some more LeBron
Gitty they kept me from falling and you
know who but it was pretty funny out
about was great I was growing you I love
so much we were talking before the show
yesterday about Cleveland and Belichick
and Chris started telling a story about
you were gonna be a brown and that chris
has a brown Sims Jersey what what is
going on
well you never I've never heard this
story yeah I flew down on a private
plane art Valdez private plane decided
contract with the Browns to play in 1995
and got there you know boom boom
everything's great you know okay let's
sign the contract they wanted me to sign
a different contract that was for
minimum pay and I said whoa well that's
not what we agreed upon and there's that
and hey one thing led to another ballot
check looked at me goes man I'm so sorry
Phil which he was I know he was it
wasn't up to him and they were I think
they wanted to sign me and watch me
during training camp and decide they
wanted to pay me an I don't know I don't
really don't know about it they're
running out of money I mean there's
there's a reason yeah the money to pay
me right but Belichick years later many
times has said oh god I'm so glad you
didn't come because that was of course a
year they moved right and it turned into
a disaster but I was there and I said
okay I don't know who I said it to could
have been Mike Lombardi because he was I
think the general manager and I said
well I came down here you pulled my
pants down I guess I'm gonna go home wow
so there was a time where it would have
been Bill Belichick and Phil Simms as
the coach quarterback in Cleveland
very close 94/95 dad that was 95 95
season I set out the 94 season so 94 I
which was I still will be one of my
great memories of life because I
couldn't play eighth grade football
because I would have had to lose
twelve pounds to play offensive line
okay
and so I didn't play football and dad
was still Tom Coughlin was in
Jacksonville so right dad
you almost what Jacksonville got
interested in dad buddy Ryan and the
Arizona Cardinals were interested in dad
and I would go over to the football
field in town and I was dad's receiver
and he would throw footballs to me and
we would have workouts and cuz you have
to stay in shape you know stay in shape
and yeah that was some good bonding
moments yeah it was fun it was fun I
remember my son goes well maybe I can
lose the weight and play tight end I
said not a chance you're not doing it my
son's not playing tight in and you're
not gonna lose weight here or whatever
it is they're throwing employee right
yeah I said this is crazy you know so
well yeah it's a good thing I don't
believe even though you were tall and
all I stopped that you were overweight
to play quarterback that's what's really
funny but yeah oh well I'm sure in this
day and age they bumped those weights up
quite a bit I think they have they
definitely ever I know I think I was
like 162 and I think so and I had to be
like 148 something like that it was the
Jared Lorenzen a New Jersey high school
my senior year in high school I can
remember like it's yesterday what do you
mean right now I'm about I must say I'm
either I'm about 248 pounds probably to
be exact right so what do you think I
weighed in high school is a senior
football season I mean I've seen +8 205
I'm gonna say 181 78 somewhere in there
you're close 175 yeah you know what I
weighed my senior year of high school
well tell let's hear a guess right now
around 238 right right now you're 238
damn that kids getting this number kids
getting higher my senior high school
your senior year of high school I'm
gonna I'm gonna say - OH - I was 200
right so here's the story we all had to
get weighed and our height for the
basketball programs because we're paid
in all these tournaments and so we all
line up and everyone gets on the scale
and everyone's like 180 for
and my friend goes up Dan and he's 2
years old amis 185 and we're guessing
before each one right so I go up and
everyone's like 181 64 whatever 200 they
reset the scale because it doesn't make
sense I didn't believe it right
they redo it I get up there 200 the next
game I go in and they're all going do
and I'm hitting I hit two threes right
and it my thing for like the season was
holding up to because no one understood
how I weighed 200 pounds right I'll tell
you take me to take me to the State Fair
yeah and I'll win you a doll because I
have dense bones you do have dense I
mean we've always said that you got
those Tony Romo thighs and but yeah
that's a very deceptive
yeah very deceptive awesome 200 hey your
guys go and I played at a public school
and we had the southern Kentucky yeah in
Kentucky and and we went 5 and 5 during
the season but we won the five games
they counted and then we played a team
that we lost who we got destroyed by in
the playoffs the first round and we beat
him like 20 to nothing so that was big
you know and then we beat another team
that was probably the best team in the
state we beat them 14 13 in a playoff
game and then then you had to play
everybody plays together in Kentucky so
you have to play the private schools so
we had to play a team called Trinity
high school
yeah my warning you know they're always
international top teams or whatever and
we played and we lost
I forgot the score 12 to nothing or
something like that but we were down
inside their 10 didn't score a couple
big deal whatever but we did not have
one single person on the team that
weighed 200 pounds
not one Wow nobody was at 200 pounds
that's unbelievable
well that's you don't really it probably
wasn't that unusual right no I think I
think you're right well I was just gonna
ask you like what do you think like 80
you're 86 team right that goes and wins
the Super Bowl who's the biggest lineman
on that group Carl Nelson who is it well
no but he was you know he looked like
forward and back
cabal euronymous trim but I wouldn't
even begin to guess I must say he was
probably 270 pounds right so who do you
think the biggest guy was on the
starting line at that and that year well
let's see Brad Benson at left tackle man
you know again maybe 270 280 I think I'm
going high yeah wow this is crazy 260 I
don't you know this was he might have
been the you know cuz he really was a
great trainer and weightlifter he might
have been as high as 280 so yeah yeah it
was I'm kind of think Who am I missing
Belliard free oh yes Godfrey yeah right
Parcells called him tunnel vision you
know in other words if the guy was
directly in front of him he's blocking
the god moved one inch to his right no
do I block him still if he moves an inch
to the right and they still called him
and he was a Notre Dame you know he's
smart as hell right he's like hey tunnel
that's amazing he'll do you think he's
one he's a centimeter off of where you
told me was gonna be do I still block
him or should I try to make a call and
let somebody else block him Phil do you
think that you could make Belichick
laugh like if he was there with you do
you feel confident that you could tell a
joke they could get him to laugh oh yeah
he laughs at everything yeah yeah really
you tell him a good joke he'll laugh and
I don't want you getting the laugh
because I would bring up some incidents
that happened when he was with us you
know that I just know you go oh my god
he started start laughing yes that's
awesome
we always had moments you know if we
started talking about history in fact I
just was doing something and I would
read it - I'm the Patriots ran a play
with cordarrelle Patterson last week let
me see what I wrote about it it's a
single wing play right and I just go I
go I wonder if he's to want it that did
it so when I wrote down it's a wing T
play you yes go a counter play inside
with cordarrelle Patterson and it's out
of the Wing T right I wonder if he
thought this up because he knows all
that asking about the Wing T and for one
hour later he'll still be
my coach got I got it the Wing T was
great yeah you know how about the single
wing Oh single wing now you know her yes
so because he's read every book ever
written about football fun things so
it's sometimes it's really fun to talk
to him about this stuff all right so are
you leaning chiefs Patriots are you
leaning Saints Rams
are you leaning on this Wednesday you
know I'll tell you if you watch me on
Sunday when we come on the air you're
gonna say give you some information but
I tell anybody all right so wait I
didn't see I didn't see your picks on
Showtime yet so who did you pick in
there I know I know you're gonna you
might readjust the who'd you pick on the
show on Tuesday did you really
oh good for you yeah no I didn't I think
I'm gonna pick and it's hard to pick
game on Tuesday so I don't know he was
hilarious he was control what he said
about Marcus Peters and and that whole
thing at the end he just went on about
wide receiver Michael Thomas how they
got to defend them and just the one he
did before he cursed and said all these
other things and I mean it he knocked
his mic off and you know of course we're
laughing and that's why at the end I
said we should have played that first
one and he tried to say something I said
cuz it had been beat beat beat and that
had been good stuff cuz we would have to
listen to you and he oh god you got me
that's awesome yeah I mean he's oh my
god what comes out of his mouth
oh well Phil I'm really hoping that we
get to watch the game with you on Sunday
at Chris's house I'm putting pressure on
him Chris doesn't want us there
congratulations to having another
grandchild we were going to but then you
know your daughter had a baby and Chris
doesn't think it's appropriate for us to
be there you could listen if you called
my daughter and asked her she would say
oh yes please everybody come over
because nonstic uterine cancer
there's nothing like a party she'll make
it up I know she'll throw of all time
party what's the name was
the girl Elizabeth Elizabeth Rose yes
walk in to her room and it's just I said
I looked at my wife ago you know Eve
only my daughter could have a baby and
make a damn party out of it hey you know
people are coming in and there's I was
like oh my god Oh in the hospital yeah
there was a steady flow of people she
said nothing you know talking oh I'm
okay and you know she looks I mean it
was a signing book for people to check
in congratulations great oh it was great
so happy for you pal anything else no
that's it will save your bull watch your
picks on CBS yeah you do that and you
know Christopher if you think of
anything that's clever you know I mean a
little bit clever you know I'd
appreciate it but you know it's okay I
know I will tell you one thing yeah this
won't be ducking there's just looking at
some stuff or whatever you know I'm big
atom in this the history of a play who
started it the origin of the concept all
that stuff right you know Bill Walsh the
you know fake sweep left and roll right
and throw it to the fullback coming
underneath right in the flat you know
now it's the one charge on scrambled for
on the fourth down to get the N body
does it 9,000 different ways and the
Kansas City Chiefs did one last year in
the opening game I think up in Alex
Smith do it twice he missed it the first
time it was a Kareem hunt who called a
long touchdown pass up the seam
yeah and turned to this yeah well they
ran some of those plays again this past
week and the week when they read it
against New England new even came back
the following week and ran it against
New Orleans yes I know so it was kind of
that was the first time I saw the play
and I told a friend of mine that and
right now he says I know 18 teams that
have run the exact play during a year
yeah so it just come that's how it
happens everybody's gonna copy it and
it's the first time I've seen a play
where went oh that's really clever and
you know in the NFL we know everybody
copies everything fast if it's good put
it in man yeah and that's what the
Pacers do so that's my seat see that's
my giving too
you son thank you thank you she's very
kind all that stuff for you there big
guy don't worry I got some stuff all
right yeah he's about to be Deuce and a
half years Oh Phil always with the
energy Oh Billy Phil my thing for Phil
was gonna be Phil you didn't factor in
Bill Belichick with extra time like well
no he's more mad that he just didn't
think at the point of Atlanta Super Bowl
Seattle Super Bowl you know Super Bowl
preparation is another level of
preparation altogether to where you're
never gonna dissect the team or a scheme
more than that all right let's go to
Colts Chiefs first we're gonna start off
with Colts offense Chiefs defense that
was the biggest surprise how the heck
did the Chiefs get in there you had a
lot of things in your notes
about Andrew Luck start there yes one of
your thing Andrew Luck's puts way too
much on his front foot leads to a lot of
floaters luck threw it like [ __ ] one of
the worst games he's ever had
yep has to fix mechanics mechanics he's
[ __ ] walking the ball to pee right so
you know being on your back foot you
know just think of uh think of Tom Brady
this PAC past weekend think of a Patrick
mahomes think of an Aaron Rodgers
anybody really that can really spin it
and throw it but yes I'm going to stand
up here just to do it but you want a
ball yeah sure I'll take a ball but like
the big thing is with him is like he
okay when you throw and if I'm sitting
here where's my camera that's my camera
like you want to be here like this on
your back foot and then you can go
through reads and then you throw when
you stay but he almost goes like this
left go where he's like this way right
and then he throws it and he's like it's
almost like a dart push it's like a dart
push almost like he basically moves up a
yard as he's throwing it so first of all
it's not good for protection it's not
good for anything but this is not a
pitching mound you don't you don't take
like a long stride and end up five feet
in front of you you know it's one thing
to get pushed your power comes from eggs
exactly right just like with anything
whether you're
hitting a forehand in tennis or the
driver at the the golf range either way
yes you want to have that balance and
slightly on the back leg because yes
that is where all your power comes from
and this has been the last few weeks
it's not just been this no no I think
this was the week it really showed
itself more than not because it was
windy and the elements and all of those
things and of course he's playing a
better football team but yeah that was a
it was even that little bit of an issue
in the wild-card game where if we all
went back and watched that game again
you'd go oh yeah he did miss a few
throws that were like on the ground or
whatever but they were up 21 nothing or
21 7 and it didn't really matter affect
the game at that point
but it showed itself and he's got it
he's definitely has to fix that aspect
he's going to shorten his career if he
continued to throw like that because he
will lose considerable rpms and throwing
the football and it's certainly not
gonna help in like games like we saw on
Saturday with the elements that's been
the theme to his entire season has been
arm strength yeah quick question yeah so
they go into the offseason whose job is
it to grab him and be like hey you're
walking the ball yeah yeah how does that
go when the season ends it'll go
something where I'm sure Frank Reich is
going to understand that and see it okay
and then the quarterback coach of course
is going to be talking about this with
Frank Reich and it would really probably
be more the quarterback coach that
broaches the subject with them to go
like hey let's go out in the field for
you know 30 minutes every day yeah and
just work on you know moving in the
pocket and staying on that back leg and
rotating through the ball instead of you
know your upper body almost leaning
forward and moving forward as you throw
it it's just not a way that you can you
know I'm trying to think of like good
mental images but like you like I said
if you watch the quarterback if you
watch Brady on Sunday if you watch Aaron
Rodgers ever it's more about they stay
on that back leg and their ability to
create the opposites and rotate out of
it and he misses that at times in terms
of the Chiefs secondary you said that
they weren't afraid of the Indiana's
Indianapolis wide receiver speed bump
and run the entire time they're nickel
set is more athletic and then you wrote
number 22 exclamation point exclamation
point yes number 22 I don't know who
that is hold on I didn't I didn't look
it up I was wondering why you're
emphasizing
I'm trying to think of what the heck I
was writing right there but hold on let
me get to oh oh oh
number 22 is Orlando Scandrick and I'm
saying he's not in the game anymore they
have they have eliminated him play later
schedule and go Scandrick did not come
in and one snap in the football game so
Wow he was a weakness they've gotten
healthy but yes guys like number 24
Jordan Lucas as safety certainly a big
deal the cha that what is a 35 is odd
what is a chav a v8 chart Chavarria
sward does a really good job has good
length good man-to-man skills so I think
they have found their best five or six
in the back end like a memory the safety
- I do Eric Murray was really a corner
in college more not but they have moved
him to safety and yes at least it puts
speed on the field and a guy who can be
reliable in passing situation the fact
that they figured out their secondary a
little bit yes and they're also getting
laurent devar date are defects of Liman
MD Chiefs are getting healthy at the
right time I definitely are yeah other
things just from that side the ball
getting to the big matchup the defensive
line you wrote the cheese front for is
whooping the Colts you said it's the
worst game of the year for Braden Smith
right and you also said Chris Jones is
great at swatting balls great eyes great
eyes overall though what did the Chiefs
front Ford do to that Indian at
Indianapolis friends well I think the
big thing it was no like schematically
like whoa this was amazing
I think what we saw really in all four
games by weeks matter okay
by week's matter and I think you know
six seven years ago and we were seeing
wild-card teams kind of have more
success in the division around and get
to the championship games we're not
seeing that very much at all anymore
because I do think that the number one
the number two seeds have figured out
right formulas as far as you know how to
practice during that week off and people
talk to each other and improve things
and the rest and the home-field
advantage is a factor there's just no
denying that but I think their freshness
like it was another instance of I turn
on the game I just a dim you know and
you're watching it on TV it just looks
like Kansas City was moving in a
different speed you know I think the
weeks of the Colts having to play all
these tough physical games were we're
certainly I think wore them out and then
you know you know the the fact that he
that Kansas City had to hear about it
all the time and how their defense has
not played good and how great the old
Colts old line was so all of this almost
going up and back with me in my personal
DNA right about are the Chiefs better
suited to attack the Colts aligned in
the Texans because one plays three four
in the other place for three is the O
not necessarily my response back to him
was the Chiefs are a better pass rushing
offensive line JJ how neat when it JJ
clowny this time yeah you're not gonna
run on those guys right but Chris Jones
is a better pass rushing defensive
tackle just in Houston and D Ford have
more speed around the edge exactly right
so I was right and they definitely right
yeah I mean JJ was never about leaps of
play or different like JJ Watt you're
right it's not a type of guy that it's
winning around the edge all the time his
ability is to split a gap or swim move a
guy real quick that he's headed up with
the tackle or the guard and he just
makes the guy miss and he beats them
with like quickness but yes to your
point D Ford is amazing at turning the
edge and flying Justin Houston could do
that and then Chris Jones can just
absolutely not only for a defensive
tackle he can get on the edge and beat a
guard like truly around the edge but his
power is like a Fletcher Cox to where he
can push guys like Quentin Nelson back
and the impressive thing when I read his
eyes as he does this while keeping
vision on the quarterback all the time I
think of the Blake bortles play where he
kind of got the intercept exactly right
he keeps his eyes up so then there he is
oh I'm pushing quit Nelson back oh I'm
not gonna get there I can see the
quarterback winding up the throw I'm
gonna try to time it out and put my big
hand up and see if I can knock it out
and he knocked down two or three balls
through the game the really big
defensive tackle that can also rush the
passer is so valuable yes I just think a
Fletcher and what we saw him do the
Saints Chris Jones in this game right
and then I look at the draft and I think
of that Quinn and Williams kid out of
Alabama yes right I'm like he's the same
body type as those I know the six five
three ten that can also out
my guard right because we're in a time
in the NFL were what Cris Collinsworth
every game talks about oh he doesn't do
well when he has to hold the ball for
over two and a half seconds and he's
really good under right so you need a
guy that's interior defensive lineman
that can also swap balls yeah swap balls
the key position out yet I almost think
that's more important than the speed
rushing outside guys I don't know if I
disagree with you there I would probably
say the same thing yeah I mean yeah
again like you're saying with all the
tricks of the trade and football right
now to to have that guy to go oh okay
well if they do run up the middle he's
there yes but you know then we can
execute with other guys to stop the
speed sweeps the outside run and then oh
they want to throw the ball quick well
he can push the pocket to where the
quarterback might not be able to see
might not be able to step into the ball
and maybe even bat a football down every
now and then she softens Colts defense
you wrote this down I forgot to Patrick
mahomes snap count usage was really an
phenomenal I mean he had the Colts
offsides almost every major third down
exactly right he'd never let them tee
off could you hear him I look alive yeah
yeah I could
so snap count and the the the use of
your voice yeah inflection what is
Patrick mahomes inflection like it's
pretty good because his voice is so
unique yeah I mean you know that's kind
of how he does it right there's yeah my
would it be in you know blue 80
I cracked Dan was in a while yes but it
is a very a job Greg maybe flexion is
certainly part of that cuz luck is good
at it
ladies great at it well the good breeze
is great at it yes but mate mahomes you
think is good in Flex I do I think
mahomes does great in flexion he had
great timing of when to do it I want a
man that had to be something that they
were beating into his brain throughout
the week you know let's not let them get
the jump on the snap count let's try to
give our o-line every advantage possible
they probably noticed on something on
film that they were good at jumping snap
down yeah and Andy was probably trying
to stay on top of that damn my voice
cracked our that was a Instagram a lot
of what you wrote to was if you play
zone against the Chiefs and your front
for doesn't get there your [ __ ] yes if
no one is open he will move he will
stretch the zone and the Colts didn't
have a difference maker in their front
four and it just you loved the play
calling of the Chiefs the way that
they'd go power and then they're gonna
go next play with the reverse right but
it sounds like the cultural and skates
you wrote that the young linebackers had
their weakest game yeah but it it really
sounds like if you don't get to my homes
with your front four yeah and you're
playing zone right it's over yes you're
in deep trouble because you know he can
squeeze the ball with just as pure arm
strength through any zone window and
then what he does and what we saw in a
few of those early third downs right
left colas right he gets out of the
pocket he scrambles to the right he
starts to attack the line of scrimmage
and now the zone linebackers like well
damn I got a receiver here but he's it's
only thirteen five and he's gonna run
and get the first so I guess I gotta go
try to get him and then my home's is
great at reading that and then he you
know throws the ball across the field
into the zone and Kelsey gets it and
it's a first down yeah so he is
phenomenal at doing that yes and then
added to that the Colts just can't play
man-to-man and some of the third and
four and five situate rows they have to
get some mana man corners because
there's no one they can trust no there's
no one they can trust and really that's
why you need man-to-man it's the third
and five or less place because jam
timing right exactly right there caught
the pike are usually he's going to call
something to get six yards and yes you
know when I mean he's gonna call
something to get out of your hands and
you want to mess that up or you know Jam
receivers who are trying to run a pick
play whatever it may be and the Colts
are certainly gonna have to find one or
two of those guys mahomes is like Steph
Curry and that like MBA defenses you
can't you can't really you he stretches
you out so much yes that it compromises
the rest of your defense and as soon as
mahomes kind of comes near the line and
you shift a little bit he could hit
anywhere
I mean Steph Curry is the perfect
analogy it really is because I I've
actually said this like he makes crazy
things look normal he makes crazy things
look normal and he is like this cute
little kid that all little kids are like
oh he looks nice I like him yeah I mean
Philip almost
seven days of the week when I come home
today I'm pretty sure Phillips will be
running around that Patrick mom's Jersey
like it's almost every day and your son
has all of them he's got Russell Wilson
Rogers this Patrick mahomes has taken
over and it's going to the fact now of
it's not just like let me put on his
jersey I got a I got to make a video of
him doing his mannerisms he's got
Patrick mahomes down after what he
throws the ball and how he sedation how
Josh just looked up but you know I know
so today I will try yes capture the
mannerism right we're gonna put it on
we're just gonna mortgage fill up we've
had a few catches in the in the family
room and he's throwing the ball and I'm
like listen I know you're trying to be
Patrick likes I know he's doing I just
know Patrick mahomes got really good at
throwing it normal first before he
started like doing like you know Johnny
trickshot okay so let's just work on
that first and he don't want to hear it
but he's got you know after releases it
he keeps his arm like this and the way
he leans he's got a Down and I'm like
damn but that's what YouTube does cuz
Phillip wakes up in the morning before
he goes to school and he turns it on and
he watches that kind of crap man but
that just need to schedule a social
shoot with Phillip and we'll just go up
there one day him Ozzy's just doing
everything yeah and then we'll just roll
it out you know every couple weeks or
you did have a note about all of the
playoffs in these notes saying that all
of the fast defence has got their ass
kicked this weekend yes they need Dallas
Chargers all the defense is built on
speed and the Eagles defense is really
built on power up front right definitely
something that just jumped out to me
Indy Dallas Chargers basically run the
same scheme to which is the Seattle
scheme and again they're really good
don't get me wrong but the problem I
continue to see go ahead you've gotta
say I was just gonna say that someone
wrote online it's ridiculous that
everyone's trying to copy the Seattle
scheme right when Seattle could have run
any scheme with Richard Sherman Earl
Thomas kam chancellor and it worked but
they are all taking this one scheme when
they could have played man-to-man all
those years and they would have been fun
you're right I mean they could have got
in the Buddy Ryan bear front and they'd
still be like man this defense is really
awesome like you're exactly right that
is a valid point by whoever is that made
that but yes I think the one thing I
see with this scheme of courses lack of
size I mean de Nico ultra is your D
tackle great year and I'm a fan of his
but 273 pound
the muddy snowy field of Kansas City
just ain't gonna get it done and playoff
football I mean you're just gonna have
to get lucky with the right matchups and
that's what you're but you're going oh I
hope we get the right matchups but that
is an issue let alone with those schemes
once again I think what we saw in all
three cases was whenever there's a
schemer as the offensive play caller and
a quarterback who can execute it the
scheme does it gets exposed constantly
and I think that's they feast on the
weak that scheme so their numbers look
good because oh man we shut down Arizona
they had 145 yards you know Arizona
sucks that's great
their offense was horrible but you know
when you if you want to hold yourself to
a playoff Superbowl standard you got to
think about Brady McVeigh Drew Brees
Sean Payton all of those type of guys
and I think you saw that get exposed
this week we know Bella checks could be
thinking about my homes this is the last
note from this game
you said you notice that mahomes escapes
to his right a lot right and the
Patriots are gonna take this away yeah
what's funny as his most famous rollout
of the season was left with the left
handed throw yes but that was on purpose
it seemed like with Denver I felt like
he had to roll out to the left a lot
neck I think they took away from
remember he roll out the left and that's
when he had the cross body throw -
Kelsey right up the scene yeah right but
you think that Belichick is gonna
purposely make sure he doesn't roll out
I do and he did it in the first matchup
but I'm gonna go back and watch the the
first matchup on film tonight and yeah I
know we did it in the first matchup he
did like he had he always had Dante
Hightower in the middle and as soon as
as soon as mahomes escaped to the right
Dante with loop to the to the to it as
well to cut it off and he threw the
interception in the end zone with Dante
Hightower kind of climbing on his back
if you remember really he had the great
throw where he escaped to the right and
the long touchdown pass down the
sidelines to Kareem hunt but there was a
few other plays in that game where he
wanted to escape right and he went oh
man I can't go there where do I go and
then he got stuck in the pocket and had
to throw it away and belt bill is
definitely going to try
do his best to take that away it's the
the I again recommend the Kevin Clark
article in the ringer because it just
really talked about the thing that the
best thing in sports is when there seems
to be an unstoppable offense and then
they play Belichick yeah and you see how
he approaches it and how he takes it
away and but I would also say that I
don't know if they faced a guy like
Patrick mahomes
and I don't know if they faced a guy
like Patrick mahomes in another person
stadium right what did repens he has
with the weapons he has and and the
offensive coordinator yeah so you were
saying that Andy Reid doesn't have a lot
of success against Bill Belichick that's
true but in the seven games in which
Bill Belichick has allowed 40 points
yeah he's got two of us three of them
that's pretty awesome you know what I
mean yeah so they face each other a lot
over the years yes and Andy to what you
wrote a lot in there about how he's not
afraid of third and short but in the
ball right Annie ain't afraid of anybody
no no Andy if Andy can just stay running
the football once again
yeah that's your big note they only ran
it 13 times last time you need it
consistent I need it just 20 and I don't
even give a damn about the yards the it
is the respect factor you have to make
Belichick think okay they still might
run it and Damian Williams is scary and
the biggest thing is when they get under
Center and they've been doing that more
lately you know you're gonna the with
the biggest throw of the day to kelsey
down the middle was a play-action pass
with him running a deep crosser look
that's the way they're gonna find those
type of plays because bills gonna be all
over some of the drop back shot plays
I'm gonna go to chargers Patriots next
just to keep this like a little seamless
and we'll do the NFC after that so
Chargers offense Patriots defense what
did the Patriots do to slow down
chargers one thing that Sims rights in
this note a lot is how what is the
coverage on the first third down yeah
you believe that's indicative of what
the game plan has been all week right
and what they did was they put Stephon
Gilmore on Keenan Allen yeah JC Jackson
on Trevor Williams and you pretty much
wrote Gilmore is the only one matching
early and Keenan Allen has no chance no
chance he is just it's an awful matchup
for Keenan Allen it's an awful man he's
not faster than Stephan Gilbert Decker
Stephon Gilmore is not gonna get pushed
around by Keenan Allen exactly right and
and in Gilmore
bored this big guy is also very quick I
mean Gilmore's one of the best corners
in football let alone he's got coaching
now to go you know when they're in this
formation and this split it's really
these three routes or member when
Buffalo media was saying that Gilmore
stunk and good riddance remember that
yeah like no Belichick has played this
guy twice a year for four years he's
been waiting for you guys to get rid of
him for this entire time right and
that's why he was so confident getting
rid of Malcom Butler
yes remember that and then we were
applauding this Buffalo reporter for
outing Stefan Gilmore's bad plays yeah
if Belichick picks up your player you
messed up yeah you messed up pretty much
you didn't realize what you had or you
weren't using them correct yeah that's
that's pretty much it left going I can't
disagree with you there and yeah that
was just
that's tough that was a tough matchup
for Keenan Allen because he just has
nothing to back a guy like Steve Stephon
Gilmore back up Stephon Gilmore never
feared his speed he got him in the
double move I understand that yeah he
was playing off it was really three
match coverage of his own coverage where
yes if he's in his area he's got a plan
like a man
they know that the charges like to throw
these skinny posts and he faked like he
was gonna run the quick post and he went
deep and Gilmore bit on it but after
that negative ghostrider it was tough
sledding you wrote the Patriots were all
over the shallow crossers it was
linebackers at the line of scrimmage
stressing protection and you and
whenever the Patriots in her big game I
feel like this is the defense they play
yeah it's the ameba defense of seven
guys you don't know who's coming you
don't who's not and the reason they can
do it is because as you wrote everybody
has the same skill set they all have the
same body type all of the Patriots
defensive linemen look the same right
numbers are different yes all their
linebackers look the same their numbers
are different right it's like Belichick
puts into a computer okay who are the
guys that fit this criteria let me trade
a fifth round pick for Kyle van Noy and
a six round pick for this guy and then
when push comes to shove in the playoffs
they can all do the same thing and
they're all interchangeable yeah his
defense is what Shaun McVeigh's offense
is it looks the same right but we're
showing we're giving you something
different every play exactly right and
it's it's just hard
- as an offense when they get in those
situations it's hard to really peg for
wait this guy blitzes or this guy drops
or you know most times you get a feel
through your week of breakdown and going
oh and they get in this defense like 92
rushes 90% of the time he might be
walking around but it all comes down to
it he's the one coming and 55 might be
dropping back but with with the Patriots
you know I just throw this is a new game
plan every way it is and it's a landing
Roberts okay and then it's Kyle van Noy
and it's Dante Hightower and it's John
John Simon and it's you know Albert
McClellan and they could put all these
different guys on the field to where you
go okay wait you know who does what they
all complain it'll live backer they all
can play outside linebacker they all
have a pass rush skill set to where yeah
I'm not saying they're von Miller but
they have the techniques and power and
aren't physically overwhelmed there to
where you just don't know who's coming
or going or or where anybody is
the other two things one you say people
don't talk about Hightower coming off
the edges yeah
yeah he's he's just um he's how is he is
he back cuz healthy he's not I don't
think ever gonna be back as far as like
the guy we saw at Super Bowl xlix
Seattle Seahawks game where arguably the
best linebacker they yeah right I mean
he was a beast then you know he's got
some like knee and shoulder issues so
there's times where you know Super Bowl
51 that sack was pretty that was pretty
awesome and he's still gonna be have his
moments because he's one of the biggest
linebackers in the history of football
but yes you know he did this at Alabama
and this is why he dropped them
Belichick I'm saying isn't he because he
could play middle linebacker but he's
got this unbelievable power off the edge
to where like it there was a few times
where he got Sam TV 69 I mean I'm sure
Sam Debbie's gonna hold this is a
linebacker ill you know and is exactly
right and he just collapses the pocket
because they they don't they
underestimate the power and you said
that if the Patriots play that defense
you have to not be afraid to throw deep
comebacks outs comebacks and rivers at
this point can't do it yes so that's but
the thing is like I thought about this
while reading your note yeah that's if
you're expecting the Patriots to play
that defense again well that's what's so
incredible at the Patriots is they might
not play that defensive
they might not they might come out like
and cover too and nope no we're just
gonna do that they could the thing
though that I think you could count on
those when they get you in obvious
passing situations they're going to do
it and we're gonna do the amoeba they're
gonna do the amoeba everything I have a
lot of different guys of the line
scrimmage you're not sure who is what
it's gonna be it could be you know three
linebackers and three defensive linemen
they bring all six on the Blitz who do
that right but my big thing was when in
doubt just you could match protect
there's a lot of these times there's a
single safety look right and if you have
a guy with speed outside that can back a
Gilmore offer and JC Jackson can sit he
has to if they do and you have a
quarterback who can throw it outside you
just gotta be willing to call it and
trust your guys that you know we can
throw 15-yard comebacks all game long
and do that that's why this game's gonna
be that's why it's fascinating right
it's fascinating because much like Saban
Bella checks only weakness and it's the
weakness for every defensive coach is a
quarterback that can go off script right
that can run around and throw the ball a
mile Cam Newton I don't know Watson
Aaron Rodgers those are guys he
struggled with you know he's a losing
record to Cam Newton he's one on one
against Aaron Rodgers you know Russell
Wilson's
2 & 1 against him deshaun Watson Shawn
Watson we saw the magic heat produced in
2017 because of your point is exactly
right like oh I can break down this
scheme but I can't break the player down
like at times there's gonna be times
where there's nothing I can do the guy
is that physically gifted and that is
the guy that scares Belichick in that
defense the most I love it all right
other side of that was the Patriots
offense Chargers D this one was
depressing to read a stupid-ass zone
from the get-go
for to a side killing the charger right
the endless array of play-action passes
is unreal
you just there's just so many different
things off the same formation right and
you said Brady is best throwing game of
the year the ball is humming it didn't
seem like they were challenged at all
never
at no point you wrote that they
eliminated Bosa Ingram with run
play-action wide receiver screen shovel
pass right they never got a chance to
really be in a situation where it's
third and seven and Brady might have to
hold the ball and I can finally come
around the edge there was never that
point there it just didn't matter you
know it was run
okay then it was you know fake the run
and we throw a screen or then it was
like I'm saying for for what I brought I
think to start it like right for
four-on-three them right they're playing
these zone coverages well they would
line up Brady in the shotgun a back on
both sides of him right two backs I got
both tailback sin James White and
Michele in right and now they got tight
into the right receiver to the right and
they would have one of the running backs
go out and run a route to the one to the
tight end side of course Gronkowski is
running a route the receivers running
that route and from the backside running
back they would fake the run but then he
would also go continue out to that side
flow this so now that it's a four on
three fast break every time just
thinking about basketball that way a lot
of people were talking about the
predictability of the Patriots offense
that when Sonia Michele was out there
was a run and when James White was out
there was a pass and it was something
like 97% of the time James White was out
there he was maybe drop back but we're
not taking to account on the play-action
passes that when Michelle was in there
and then all of a sudden oh damn it's
Adelman behind me for 10 and oh damn
it's Hogan for 15 you know that's that's
what they really I mean they were it's
amazing I just can't overemphasize this
a guy who watches football all the time
and I love looking at offenses and
quarterbacks and the nuances they do I
just really can't explain to everybody
out there how amazing it is what they do
in the play-action pass game and how
hard it is to coach the protections and
all the different run looks they give
off their play-action it is extremely
hard to figure out all those rules and
all of the things you need to do we're
gonna pull the guard and pass protection
and still block you know the four good
pass rushers yeah and all of that like
to you what you're saying
the announcers always love when a
quarterback sells a play-action right
but the Patriots don't just have a
quarterback selling the play-action they
have a guard and a tackle selling the
play-action to a level that no other
team would do right that's what you got
kind of sad because a lot of other teams
might run play-action and they're doing
it with the quarterback and running but
all the linemen are standing I'm doing
that right or they've done a slide step
but meanwhile when the Patriots to a
play-action
they dent
the entire defensive line like they're
pulling to the left meanwhile like
there's three routes going and it messes
with your keys as a second level player
linebacker while they linebacker wise
German James he's being told all week
hey when this could've been this guard
pulls they'd like to run this place so
get ready to come up there and fill the
hole so then he sees it and he said oh
I'm rare to fill the hall oh crap there
goes at them and behind me 425 that's
why the well the Eagles didn't really
have success cuz they let up 33 points
but teams that can just only rush their
front four and have success their
linebackers can almost sit back in
passing defense the whole time yeah the
problem of the Eagles what they did in
that game is they just started playing
man-to-man on every play and that was
what the two other notes from this that
were interesting yet one you said Brady
show compassion to me bein after the
touchdown very cool right very cool I
believe it was the first touchdown they
score he's kind of walking up to the end
zone to celebrate and me bein crosses
his face and you could he kind of grabs
them and says something to him but I
thought that was a classy thing for Tom
to do it was classy a Bob craft before
the game exactly exactly right that was
really was that was a cool thing because
you can't imagine the struggle a guy
like Brendan me Baines had to go through
in his own mind the last week or so
going back to an old-school guy right
there we go a guy who's like you know
what I'm gonna play this is what I do
and my family would be proud of me and
it probably took his mind off of it for
the first is nope right uh you did right
though Brady is flinching like the 85
Bears are after him no one is within
five well it was like these are just
little context close okay it's not like
he was flinching all game because he was
pretty clean but like on the first drive
of the game they ran the Kansas that he
played my dad was just talking about
where the back came out and ran up the
seam and if he just throws it to him
he's gonna throw a touchdown I could
pull it up on the film real quick if you
wanted to see it but you know also he's
being told all week don't hold the ball
too long cuz Ingram and Bose are coming
and he's worried about that's been one
issue with their pass protection on the
edge all year but yeah he has it he's
wide open it's gonna be a touchdown but
it's like everything he's thrown to that
point is so quick and it's happened so
fast so now you had to Pat the ball for
a second and he was like look guy
getting out of my hand and I was
what are we rushing for wait wait but
that's been one little issue with Brady
all year long yeah like the Dolphins
game exactly right and I'm just in the
even in the Bills game a few times I'm
just saying those are things I write
that down just to remind myself for this
week against Kansas City to go well
these are some you know animals for lack
of a better word to are gonna become an
F but you did say that he was throwing
the ball incredible what's I think he's
looked in a while that's why I like it
just
he doesn't have to quit I mean it just
you know as long as he's willing to get
hit his throwing is still it's top notch
I wonder what Giselle's thinking I don't
like gizelle is either loving the free
time because remember she came out the
concussions after a few Super Bowls like
her if Tom Brady loses to that Atlanta
game I wonder if he retires like if he
never makes that comeback yeah and then
Giselle's up there yelling and he's on
the ground after throwing the pick six
and they never make the combat yeah
because when you come back from 28 to 3
I mean you come back from any yeah
you're pretty much right I mean I won't
want to argue it you can come back from
24 to 10 on the Seahawks the year before
right and I ought to go Deb you lost
that and then you lose the AFC
championship game to Denver the next
year you might be like retiring you
might have been like damn the hell with
this okay we don't have it anymore but
but no one's gonna go to Tom Brady and
say you're done no no Tom Brady has
earned the right to go as long as he
wants and I've always believed it's more
Josh McDaniels related for Tom than
anything look if Josh went to Indy this
year yeah and the offense wasn't that
great cuz it's not Josh McDaniels right
is Tom thinking about it then sure I
think but the whole band still together
they're still together and they
understand where tom is out of in his
career and you know they do a good job
of trying to protect him so they realize
he's 41 and that he's not gonna stand in
there all day like he was when he was 29
and just like get lambaste at at times
and all that Patriots cheese it's gonna
be amazing
it is alright Cowboys Rams Rams offense
Dallas defense Rams defensive line this
was you were so impressed at the
newfound discipline of the Rams
defensive line they're not being their
typical reckless self ad and Sue Erin
Donald and Sue were two gaps a lot more
sum-sum su played really well su played
like game of the year game of the year
just you know disruptive plays and you
know I'm not even like a hundred percent
sure they were too gapping some of those
plays I believe they were they're not
really a team that likes to live in the
to gap world but man there was a whole
lot of plays where Aaron Donald's
holding up Zack Martin and then
disengage or Sue's doing that the other
way and you know what the other thing it
did left Co the fact that they played so
much discipline and you said this on
Monday I don't know if he said in the
pod right and he said it to me we were
just like talking like you got to see
the kid little Littleton right yeah
because he had gaps he had he didn't
have to worry about he's like I don't
know where these guys in front of me are
gonna go I just have to react and and
play it's just so hard at times so the
fact that they were more discipline
allowed him to just T off and go get the
ball you said there's certain runs you
can't do versus Aaron Donald yeah Wade
Phillips makes it so hard to help on
Aaron down yes he does like if he's what
place can you not run on Aaron down like
early on you got to be careful if he's
the three technique right on the outside
shield pull in the left guard exactly
right like you've got to be careful
because he'll be back there to set up
hold with the guard and they're running
back to get the ball and hit back hello
I'm here when they tried to get Tyron
Smith to cross it Donald and block on
the right side could you ask him to do
anything wrong Tropic Thunder yeah I
don't even know what other way to put it
that's all there is like that's
ridiculous like it's not realistic to
ask that's what I was thinking yeah that
was almost as ridiculous as Troy Aikman
saying Robert Woods was the best wide
receiver in the NFL oh did he say that
yes
damn okay he said arguably and then came
back later and said he's my but he's my
number one wide receiver in the NFL
wow that's that strong I think Robert
Woods is up there for most underrated
yeah I would agree with that too but I
don't think he's no I would i would
argue he was the third best receiver on
the field that day I mean but but either
way you also said there were some
passing situations where they asked
Ezekiel Elliott to chip Aaron Donald and
you wrote you never use a running back
to chip a defensive tackle I'm just
saying like I've never seen it that's
more like I was saying like well you
know you're running about just step up
and help or or he run through on the
route and hit him on the shoulder right
or just they run through on the route of
the instant well usually when a running
back goes inside
just trying to find a lane to get out so
he can be the check down or whatever
else I've seen running backs chip on von
Miller's and speed passes on the edge
but this was a flake there was probably
two or three plays where they were like
no Connor Williams set inside and Zeke
will take away his out shoulder so he
can watch right don't ever use that you
don't like it no I'm saying I just I
guess never seen it that's what I'm
saying that was like new to me I was
like whoa like I was Cowboys big wrinkle
I was like whoa whoa don't work it did
it definitely did the few times they did
it yeah Aaron Donald got hit by Zeke and
Connor Williams is in perfect position
but you know back to the point to of
where you know Wade Phillips when he
gets you an obvious passing situations
he makes it very hard at times for you
to send your center and guard at Aaron
Don why because he'll send he'll line up
in something where like three of the
linemen are on one side to where now the
center has to go with a three lineman
side and now the guard has to be
one-on-one he's like that much of a mess
man he can yeah he's he's an issue man
he is he's unbelievable it sounds like
offensive lines versus Aaron Donald it's
like defensive backs versus Tyree kill
yeah we're like you could put Tyree
killer one side and then three on the
left and you're like I really want to
double Tyreke I got all their receivers
on one side that's the out that's that
they put you and they put you in a
predicament that's why it's very
important like in the Rams you got to be
careful because once you get to third
and six or more you're playing their
kind of game yeah you also said and
teams are not afraid to play man versus
Dallas because they're calm their
concepts are so easy yeah I was so right
on this game yeah you were I just your
notes from that Dallas team right I like
look back at you picking Dallas and I go
you were all over Dallas they're too
simple like for me it was like did you
really think Jason Garrett in that one
week was gonna go now I'm gonna coach
like that's what I just didn't I know
you're right you're right I was wrong I
guess I just didn't believe the rams
would play disciplined run defense
that's where I just came down well you
did right give Wade Phillips a lot of
credit for changing his DNA yeah he did
what did he change well he discipline
nature born like his whole approach
really the last few weeks of the year
was just like wait I have talent
I don't need to scheme so much if we
just kind of play it like close to the
vest I mean he coached that Denver D I
don't know why he didn't just do the
exactly I know and I was saying he was
probably more complicated and even then
than he is now yeah he would do like
some different wrinkles then now they're
like you know hey it's it's 3:00 match
it's you know Tampa - it's very simple
stuff but they don't need to get
creative because they're they're fast
and talented to wrap up the dalit the
Rams offense Dallas D and my voice
starts from trying to do that yes it
does I have this in here and I guess it
was on the wrong side yes it's actually
the Rams offense so we'll switch now
okay the Rams doubled Cooper and it
seemed like in your notes that debt that
dak wasn't seeing the field well I
that's spot on that dak did not have his
best day like I felt like there was a
few times where dak it took him forever
to get off the first read and the Rams
did a good job early on I'm just doing
one or two things so I think we're
Dallas was like oh no they're doing this
and then they really didn't do them
again they went back to what they do but
like one of the first third downs of the
game they had Marcus Peters on the
single side against Amari Cooper to the
left side the quarterbacks you know and
the shotgun you have three receivers to
your right yeah and Amari Cooper's to
the left all by himself Dallas by a
general rule for the most part when they
see that coverage and they're single
safety they would go we're just gonna
let him re Cooper work on there over
there and dak I'll throw it to him well
what they did was like they would go
okay Marcus Peters has got him but then
LaMarcus Joyner who was the free safety
that was down he would buzz out
underneath them to take away the hitch
rattle it's a very Zimmer thing to do so
it was really cool like he just they
just did a little things like summer
does that with Harrison Smith he does
he'll do it a lot right cuz if he feels
like you're a team that likes to throw
the singles cutaway in he's just gonna
make it like cloudy for you you know you
want to sit there and wait all day or
whatever it has got a lot of confidence
and deck going forward I do I think dak
dak nonetheless is the franchise
quarterback for them I think he is yes
he is
I mean I think that a lot like how marty
morning wag has gone in baltimore yeah I
feel very similar about morning morning
Wade this way I feel a lot Scott Linehan
where we've seen your system now for 15
years yeah it's a good system yeah but
you're not a good week to week coach
you're not in you're not inviting a lot
of new wrinkles right and now that we
know we got a Mari and I think Gallup is
turning into not a bad number 2 or 93
right you get another weapon in there
that we I just need to see some
creativity I think I don't I don't see
the EZ completions for deck and I don't
consider in a Morey Cooper slant an easy
completion no I agree that's just like I
mean that's just light of the Jason
Garrett quotes where he's like our
system is fine it can work I don't like
anyone saying no that's it's just not
right now they need they need to add
more to that offense and come up with
more bread-and-butter plays that are
creative to your point and you know just
the last thing on dak to dak at least
the last six seven weeks of the year he
threw the ball really well he made good
decisions and I think the big thing with
dak to and this is like you want this as
your franchise quarterback he's tough as
hell tough as hell he he is not afraid
to take blame I wanted run him more he's
a leader like he's a leader of men and
he is a man and I think those are things
you like I think he's elite in short
yardage rushing such as shares his
ability to cross the goal line what him
and Zeke both have elite traits at
finding holes and gaps and extensions
back collision for the touchdown run he
had with Cory Littleton I mean that was
like I I would have been concussed he
can use a monster the Mack try six for
240 years of the line I know and he's
got a great pair of ass and legs on them
so Rams Rams offense Dallas defense the
most shocking part of your notes Rams
interior offensive line is having its
way with Cowboys defensive tackles yes
the much beleaguered offensive line but
do they have healthy guys back now at
center or guard because savvy they were
banged up but no I mean Sullivan looked
like he had a great game they did but
you know great game and total scheme
exposure you know
there's two things that jump out to me
just to connect dots first thing is Rod
Marinelli
the defensive coordinator said this
month right Joe buries his son-in-law
Aaron Cromer the offensive line coach
for the Rams he was in Tampa with me we
were all in Tampa together all of us
what are you so they knew so I'm just
saying they knew the nuances there but
the lack of adjustments on the defensive
side of the ball so here's the one basic
thing they did a million times in a row
go ahead I was gonna say when you when
you talk about the under front yeah
explain it yeah okay so all right so
what the Rams did over and over to the
Cowboys and everybody at home you watch
the game and you saw the fake speed
sweep and then the run up the middle but
what they did is they had let's just say
they started the tight end to the left
and if they had what they call a shade
nose so they're right right so you got
your so just be everybody be the
quarterback at home okay your tight ends
to your left you're coming up under the
center and there to your left is the got
your left guard in the three technique
the guy on the outside shoulder of the
left guard and then to your right is the
shade no Sako who's on the right edge of
your center right between the center and
the guard on your right exactly right
well anytime they saw that they had must
had two plays called model and they
would go oh okay they're in that they
would motion the titanite across to the
shade nose to the shade no side and now
it becomes an under front which is under
just means like the shade nose is the
first deep defensive tackle who you're
accounting for that's what we call the
under front in the NFL and they ran some
plays off of that too because they
wanted to run it into that front so let
alone with that and then Dallas way over
committing to the fake speed sweeps they
just ran plays that I don't care if you
brought back you know Reggie white Mike
Singletary Lawrence Taylor and everybody
that you were not gonna be able to stop
schematically what they were doing with
this play and how they were lined up now
everybody out there is gonna go
what could they have done differently
well first of all they kept bumping the
linebackers way over to stop the speed
sweep so they weren't even like in
between the guard Center guard box there
right they were on the more of the edges
at times but the other team the other
thing teams would do in that case would
go you know they're always motioning to
our shade nose and they're killing us
well when I in my experience against
good defenses they start to realize that
and they go hopefully we have to shift
our line now the shade knows he's got a
bump outs now when you see the
linebacker run up and smack my go you
gotta get out you got to get out you
come down and now you guys got a switch
role does that adjustment happen at all
never not one time so I'm seeing Chris
Rashard yelling at the linebackers on
the sidelines and yet the coaches were
it's not realistic to ask what like van
Dhiresh was horrible yeah you wrote down
that Jaylon Smith and Van der s looked
confused all over the place yeah vandura
specifically looked clueless and playing
soft they had to take him out and he
wrote it's not like Shawn Lee did any
better Shawn Lee I mean it sounds like
they were in an unwinnable situation
actly right that's all it really came
down to Shawn Lee came in I think they
thought like oh he'll fix it yeah yeah
right they ran like one of the big runs
of the day was when Shawn Lee was in
write up so no what was it about running
at the shade nose that worked so well
well because really and I wish I could
draw this play up for everybody but it
just give them a mismatch yeah it just
gave them a mismatching because they
were afraid of the speed sweep by having
the shade nose he's almost pinned in the
inside and they would double him one of
the goals the second level on to the
middle linebacker now they were too far
the other anxiety right and they were
all pinned they would cut it off you
know what it's my number one Matt in
play when I would play yeah so I wait
and I'm not to put myself in the same
thing a shot like that well but I would
just put all the Y receivers on the left
yeah and I would shade that way and I'm
like I'm just running up that right sure
they ran what we would call it to the
bubble all game long which was the hole
between the shade nose and the end guys
because really the guard tackles wide
open right the guards got nobody on them
so it's easy to get to that second level
exactly right so they ran the plays they
wanted to run against the defense they
wanted to run it against almost all the
time so it wasn't even really about
hands and all that stuff I don't
when that story came out it really was
where's the shade nose guy in motion or
if they're already there right we're
just we'll just keep it I just can't
imagine they didn't shift I it's it's
mind-boggling okay so it wasn't that
late in vain the rush was bad
no alice's coaching staff didn't know
they got they got abused there's no buts
about that every play you wrote had
misdirection in it they really took
advantage of the aggressiveness Cowboys
shift the front you wrote holy [ __ ]
second half is the same [ __ ] you were
shocked yeah like your notes showed me
that you were shocked that there was
nothing
and you wrote mcvane chrome are schooled
Mira Nellie and rich art yeah what's
incredible as you know all these guys
and you spelled Cromer with a C and
Miran le Marinelli but no I've only I've
never met these people that I can spell
its gromer with a K I'm almost possibly
even now but then you also wrote you
also wrote gruff Goths throwing is
concerning yeah not good quality
footballs yeah that's why I'm leaning
Saints right now because even in a game
in which the game planning was perfect
and the end golf had time yeah yeah
there was um you know yeah I look at the
quality of focus all - between it's not
about just the completion in the yards
it's the way the ball comes out of your
hand and all of those things looking for
the pop yeah and it's not there right
now here's a little insight for our
podcast listeners four years ago before
the draft Chris Sims was one of the
first people aboard the carson wentz
train everybody was on Aaron Rodgers
including Matt Miller and Connor Rodgers
damn excuse me Karen cough excuse me
that was a huge Freudian slip
they were all over Jared Goff yeah and I
had realized at that point when it came
to quarterbacks I'm riding my sims I and
it's proven to be the same way Patrick
my home's all those guys you but you
when it comes to quarterbacks I trust
you so I said I'll bet on Carson Wentz
this is before the Eagles drafted him
right and I made a bet with Connor
Rodgers of the stick to football podcast
that Carson Wentz will be a better
quarterback and we said after three
years we'll weigh in right it's so hard
to tell who's better
but like Carson Wentz is a better
quarterback than Jared Goff I mean yes I
don't I don't I mean I don't know
anybody that would really
argue that other than some Rams fans I
know what if he came back to me and said
you know Carson Wentz isn't the best
quarterback on his own team but you know
availability Carson Wentz hurtin stuff
there's this shoes there but I look at
Jared Goff and I go he's not on the same
field physically no as Carson Wentz no
he's not Jared Goff is a really fine and
I fell quarterback but you know you can
win a Super Bowl a chair a guy
exactly right you damn damn right you
can um but yes he's not gonna he's not
gonna like McVeigh he's not like oh gosh
I can call these plays with Goff cuz he
can move and throw these lasers all over
the field that's not gonna happen he's
gonna have to find plays that he goes I
think Golf is comfortable running this
play and this fits what he does Gough
looked amazing in the chart in the
Chiefs Rams game on that Monday night
right but now we look back at the
seasons the whole we go I was against
the Chiefs defense yeah we know
Scandrick was on the field right we know
what was going right in there he's a
good quarterback but I'm a little bit
worried in the Superdome yeah you don't
know yes
all right so now let's go to Eagle
Saints and we're gonna wrap it up here
early on Eagles were this is Eagles
offense Saints defense early on Eagles
pushing Saints around in the run game
yeah they were they were controlling the
line of scrimmage for sure in the first
quarter both sides you wrote Lattimore
is back his speed is back and on that
interception
Foles had it 10 the 15 yard under throw
just a bad toss bad John immediately man
he did I mean what we would call like
why chase take off right so it was Tampa
to the outside receiver ran a post to
kind of take away that safety and now
that safeties not there and now here
comes H who's gonna run like a corner
and then roll it up as a go and now
Latimore's behind cuz he's playing cover
to so he's playing his own he's go hurts
head like four yards he had him I mean
no joke it was about a 10 to 12 yard
under throw where if he just throws it
out there ours is gonna go get the ball
he's got him beat and it's not a
man-to-man situation is his own it was
it perfectly dialed up play call but
yeah Bowles tried to kind of like place
it up there instead of really just
driving it and let it go
you explained what happened on that
Aguilar quick throw that foals was
protected he just didn't think he was
because he saw a blitz yeah which sucks
because he would have had time he would
have had that that would have been a big
play the RAM I mean the Saints did a
really good job of not doing anything
like mind blowing on defense but never
really calling the same defensive
coverage twice in a row changing looks
disguise has really played simple
coverages but never let I think the play
callers and Peterson and grow get a feel
for like oh they're doing this on this
down yeah you give a lot of that credit
to Dennis yes you said that when Brandon
Brooks uh went out it was huge in the
running game it was the Saints took over
the line of scrimmage cam Jordan got
came alive and really I forgot that
Brooks and Rankin's went down like two
and a three plays
I think Cox was like I plays later yeah
the turf monster was was alive but you
really said it wasn't just the right
guard was new ski the rest of the
offensive line really got yeah they
started to get beat up a little bit as
the game was a confidence thing yeah I
mean cam Jordan started having his way
with you know Lane Johnson and the right
side
I mean um gorg I mean I Unger uh your
Dambach Kelsey had a few plays here and
there where ya guys just you know there
was more mistakes than we saw in weeks
past and the Saints have a deep D line
and they were fresh and you know I think
that that all played into it as well and
the thing that killed me yeah the
interception to end the game apparently
on the other side foals had a touchdown
they had I think foals was I know this
play okay so yeah I think that's hold on
run ran the slant
yeah they basically ran Valjean was
running what for a cover to concept if
there's two safeties they were
telephones work to your left side and
the inside guy runs like a 15-yard in
cut and now Shawn's running a five-yard
straight across that clears out some
people right now Shawn comes over right
because if it's covered - you kind of
get the will linebacker out there and he
goes with that guy who's running the
deeper in cut and now there's an area
but I think they fooled follows on the
coverage they went to a single safety
look they were showing like they were
gonna do deep they've rolled the single
safety and he should have been on the
other side where there was a post and
then Hertz
running a corner and the back in the
flat it's like a three-level concept
he's got the post for a touchdown and
then the post I believe that was out
Giller
yeah he's got him for attention I can
pull it up real quick if you want to see
you later okay but he's got that if he
wants it and even if he doesn't he's
gonna have a hi-low on the guy in the
curl flat area with the guy who runs to
the corner in the back where if he's a
real slow piss they rushed it yeah
exactly right cuz the big thing is why
do you need to get that play off I know
I don't want to do briefs to have any
score the guest for the game-winning
touchdown with eight seconds other side
of the ball how did Drew Brees do you
wrote first play of the game which was a
pic should have been a house house ball
BRE breeze had to put everything to
throw 40 yards they couldn't get it
there yeah breezes arm is a little
concerning in the game I can't lie
you know breeze was told made some great
throws and pressure and some of the in
cuts he hit to Michael Thomas you know
he had people in his face and he threw
it in there like it was it was it was
beautiful as timing as rhythm all that
but yes when some of those power throws
are there to be had like he threw a I
think on the first or second the second
Drive of the game he's got like a 12
yard out route to Teddy Ginn and I mean
damn I mean he had to like give it
everything he had to get it there and
Russel Douglas almost picked it was
gonna pick six they ended up being
incomplete but there was a few throws in
the game where I was like damn it's
there but Brees just can't you know he's
kind of limited and how far he can
launch the ball or drive the ball when a
deep post or a deep seam route might be
open
you wrote the biggest thing about that
fake punt was other than taking Cox away
yeah is it kept that Philly defense on
the field yeah and kind of really
started to wear them down because before
that you wrote Cox Bennett and Jernigan
were unstoppable
and you know what Fletcher Cox Menaul
most want to say I don't want to be a
jerk I don't but I almost I don't think
he believed they were really gonna fake
it and that's why he just got taken back
I mean he just didn't fire off the ball
he's got guys blocking him they got no
business blocking him I mean none I mean
it's not there's no wasn't one office
alignment in there I think he just
thought like okay our defense is in here
they're clearly not gonna run this play
and Sean Payton is crazy and he said no
no we are
we're gonna run it and we're just gonna
wedge it in there and yeah [ __ ] hurt
his knee you know that's who and you
know came back after a while of like
missing plays and went out again yeah
and then went out and then came back and
looked really good like him and Rasul
Douglas like like Rasul Douglas I don't
know what happened with him what was his
injury I don't know either but I mean
your man Hawkins totally messed up the
fourth and two touchdown no [ __ ] it was
the perfect play call they had it ready
I'm okay when you like give me the my
man [ __ ] he my man all right I don't
know this guy okay
I'm not claiming them yeah he wrote
worse Eagles or yours your worst game of
the year for Andrus peat yeah I I've
never I mean that's the Fletcher Cox
movement that's he can make you have
your worst game of the year he can and
Jernigan too I mean they all they
jernigan had one moment during the game
yeah where they had the overhead camera
and he just started dancing and he's got
all the gold teeth and he's like hey hey
like I love defensive linemen like that
I know yeah well you know what I got
pissed off at when he gets the one play
when they're backed up and they called
them for like taunting like come on I
don't want to see taunting penalties for
just talking crap and the NFC divisional
playoff game like what about what you're
supposed to do what about when Denis
coatt rerolls his body right well I
don't want to see that you know my
thoughts about that they're not a big
fan of Franks and beans in my face are
not my favorite thing but talking [ __ ]
and like really no one would even known
he was talking [ __ ] he was not making
any democracy
he was just leaned over telling alvin
kamara like probably you ain't [ __ ]
go nowhere we're stopping you all day
and they throw a flag like I hate that
crap
come on the other things that you had
here you said Michael Thomas in traffic
no one is better nobody I mean a so
that's where he's number one that's
where he's number one yes I mean he's
just fearless he's like he does
definitely feels like a small tight end
you know what I mean he's yeah I would
argue I he's more physical than Earth's
I mean that's what I would say right and
hurts is the tight end he's just Oh your
body dump on me or I'll Russell with you
and then I'll jerk my hands over the
last second and I'll squeeze the ball
and get a completion rate to Mike yeah
and you wrote Sean Payton's ability to
stay with the running game as a skill
skill I mean he just I go back to what
jim schwartz in the first matchup do you
remember this quote know where he said I
still think sean has Bill Parcells in
his ear saying don't forget to run the
ball and I mean that's where I think
Sean Payton's geniuses is not that he's
worried about yards but he's going to
continue to make you defend that and try
to wear your defense a line out it's one
that's why those 18 play drives are
suffocating yes because you're going oh
here we go
third and six and it's the Kamara run
and you're like damn I feel helpless as
I have no idea what's coming
yeah he's he's great at staying with it
even when it's not going good and then
the other one you wrote was Taysom Hill
can fly he is a [ __ ] weapon well that
was another play where breeze you know
if you remember right they were on
Taysom Hill he's that wide receiver and
a tight split and it's it's three match
I mean he's written by Avante Maddox I
mean he's like he is moving and breeze
comes off play action pass and just
can't get it to him he just can't reach
him so Wow yeah because breeze is a
little bit maxed out at about 45 to 49
yards I mean that is all he's got you
should challenge him at the Super Ball
to see who could throw it farther
because it I just realized that this
whole time I've been rooting for chief
Saints or Chiefs Rams cuz I just I'm
done with the Patriots but a Patriots
ain't Super Bowl is just gonna be
Belichick go and beat me deep beat me
deep drew yeah I don't yeah you're I
mean my first thought was that's not the
best matchup for the Saints is the
Patriots know it's the worst yeah
because the Chiefs it's man-to-man it's
Michael Thomas take on that guy but the
Patriots Bill's gonna get up on
everybody Gilmore could go mess with a
guy like Michael Thomas and there's life
hard and JC Jackson certainly can cover
anybody else and then New England has
big people up front to slow down the run
like the best thing about what we're
doing right now is I don't I didn't get
any good insight for the betting show
tomorrow because it's all four teams
played really well yeah and it's really
gonna come down to like it's an
interesting betting weekend yeah it is
so I mean I don't even
what are the spreads right now do you
want to just throw them out to me right
now three and a half Saints her favor
still in three cases favored wrap three
and a half and three spreads are in your
inboxes yeah that's how close these
games are and will be so we have the
betting show tomorrow we'll announce how
far you are behind you still have a
chance to come back do I really I mean
if you get them right and I get them
wrong yeah you need to pull left go you
need to hope that I pick teams that you
don't pick Yeah right
hmm it's hard on you've read my nuts
that's hopefully I didn't leave any
tells in there this week now I'm waiting
for the time well the good thing is all
four teams like we're clearly the better
teams this week yes I get disappointed
when we get to championship weekend and
I go man one of the four should not
really got outplayed in one and that's
when you can have a bad Super Bowl
matchup or a bad AFC championship you
like the Colts beating the Broncos out
in Denver but remember that year yes
right play game right right all right so
again email Sims and left go at
gmail.com if you want to come to Atlanta
to one of our shows it's filling up
quickly Tuesday at 5:00 Wednesday at
5:00 Thursday at 6:00 Friday at 4:30 hit
us up on social josh is always posting
fire content and we're hoping to get
Phillips mahomes impersonation sometime
soon yeah for Sims peace out homies for
federic good evening everybody and for
the lef koe man we will holla holla
holla at you later ha
[Music]